-Welcome, everybody.
Welcome, welcome.
Please enjoy yourself.
Welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
Thank you for watching.
Thank you for being here.
Well, guys, it seems like
there's so much
going on right now.
You got Prince William
and Kate Middleton.
They just launched
their own YouTube channel.
Cicadas are returning
after 17 years.
Yeah. Oh, they are.
Sunday is Mother's Day.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And I heard about a woman
who claims to have found
a cigarette in her taco
at Taco Bell.
There's a lot to go over,
so let's just jump in
and cover it all at once.
It's time for a "News Smash."
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
First up, Prince William
and Kate Middleton
have launched their own
YouTube channel.
They plan to upload videos,
though it's not clear how often.
They could post every day
or they could post
once every 17 years.
That's right --
the cicadas are back.
Experts are expecting trillions
of these loud, obnoxious bugs
to emerge from underground
just in time for
Mother's Day.
It's this weekend, so if
you haven't bought a gift,
you should get on that,
though mom would be happy
with whatever you get her,
as long as it isn't
a taco with
a cigarette inside.
That's right -- a woman said
she found a damn cigarette
in her Taco Bell meal.
That's disgusting.
To be honest,
I'd rather find a
cicada.
They only pop up
once every 17 years,
so it's easy
to forget about them,
but it's okay, as long as
you don't forget about
Mother's Day.
I mean, how could you?
Flowers, cards, chocolates --
Mother's Day stuff
is everywhere.
No matter where you turn,
you can't escape it,
kind of like
the royal family.
Every TV show and movie
is about them,
and now they're
taking over YouTube, too.
I can't wait to see their
first prank video, when they
put a cigarette
in someone's taco.
What a terrible meal.
It is the opposite of
what you'll get on
Mother's Day.
And you get to eat in it bed.
So, in conclusion,
this should be fun,
there's going to be a ton,
mom, you're number one,
think outside the bun.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This has been a "News Smash."
♪♪
Oh, hey, this is exciting.
Today is National Nurses Day.
Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's what I'm talking about.
Absolutely.
Yep, after Cinco de Mayo,
everyone spent the day either
thanking a nurse or needing one.
And listen to this.
The CDC just announced that they
expect to see a sharp decline
in COVID cases
in the U.S. by July.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's right.
So get ready for
Etsy's newest item --
bikinis made from
recycled masks.
This gives me hope that we can
celebrate the 4th of July
the way it's meant
to be celebrated --
at a neighbor's barbecue,
judging their house and
trying to leave.
Speaking of COVID, I read that
the Mets and Yankees
will soon offer
free tickets to people
who get vaccinated
at their games.
That's fantastic.
Then, after parking,
food, and a T-shirt,
the vaccine will only
cost you about 400 or 500 bucks.
It's actually a great idea,
except they're having
the peanut vendor
hurl the needle at people.
You can also look for the guy in
the parking lot who's yelling,
"Pfizer! Get your ice-cold
Pfizer here!"
I'm kidding.
Fans just have to
show up on time
and hope that Mr. Met
has steady hands.
Meanwhile, I saw that
New York City is
taking the effort a step further
and now wants to
start vaccinating tourists.
-Ooh!
-I can't wait to see
a German tourist be like,
"Yeah, I just got ze
J&J at ze M&M store."
Yeah, that's right --
tourists are excited.
They're like,
"It's New York City.
We're going to get stabbed
one way or another."
The vaccines would be
administered in a mobile van.
Here's a word of warning
to tourists.
If someone rolls up in a van
and offers you a shot,
don't get in,
unless it's Mr. Met.
Some news from overseas.
I read that Russia just
authorized use of
a one-shot COVID vaccine
called Sputnik Light.
Which means everyone lining up
in Russia is hearing,
"We're out Sputnik.
Is Sputnik Light okay?
Is that fine?
It tastes the same, basically.
I mean, it's just as effective."
Some news from Washington.
I saw that house Republicans
want to kick Liz Cheney
off of their leadership team
because she refuses to
side with Trump
and say the election was stolen.
You can tell Republicans also
upset Dick Cheney,
'cause they were like,
"We should totally ditch Liz."
She's such a..."
[ Imitates whooshing ]
-[ As Darth Vader ]
Liz, I am your father.
-Liz Cheney said Republicans
have to choose between
the truth and trump,
to which Republicans said,
"Um, the truth
never gave us free hats."
You guys getting tired?
It's alright.
[ Laughter ]
We're almost at the end.
Some entertainment news.
HBO just released
the first images from its
"Game of Thrones" prequel
series, "House of the Dragon."
Yeah, here's one of
the photos they released.
We don't know much,
but you can tell that
they're not brother and sister,
because they're not making out.
Can we zoom into
the background for a second?
How did they miss that?
-Oh, come on!
-Come on!
-How did they miss that?
You'd think someone would --
-Learn their lesson.
-Well, now can we zoom out?
What's going on?
-Oh, come on!
-I've seen those people
in the Hamptons.
-Really?
-Did you guys see this?
Last night, the New York Rangers
and Washington Capitals
played each other,
and the game was pretty wild
right from the start.
Take a look at this.
-Dowd and Garnet Hathaway --
they combined for
2 goals, 3 assists.
-Here we go.
Right off the draw.
-And right off the face-off,
three fights simultaneously.
Rooney and Dowd.
-People were calling it
"The View on Ice."
Yeah, there were six fights
in the first five minutes,
and a photo of the Capitals'
penalty box went viral.
Look at this.
Yeah, it looks like
a Canadian prison.
Can we see it again?
It looks like
a white-guy vending machine.
Hey, get this --
in Ohio, lawmakers introduced
a new bill against
distracted driving.
Okay? And on the same day
that that bill was proposed,
one senator
tried to hide the fact
that he was driving
during a meeting.
Watch this.
-We're going to allow for
the legislative process
and discussions to continue.
-On the regular agenda,
are there any holds,
no votes, or abstentions?
Senator Brenner.
-No holds.
[ Laughter ]
-The guy was like, "What? what?
The seat belt?
Yeah, when I get this
rocking chair moving,
who knows what's gonna happen?
I'm not in a car.
You're in a car."
Then he was like, "Sorry.
My Zoom's cutting out.
I'm going through a tunnel.
I mean, I'm not going
through a tunnel.
I mean, I'm going through
a tollbooth.
I mean, not a toll--
Why would I say tollbooth?
I'm just going to pull over.
I'm going to pull my house over.
Hold on."
And, finally, a 12-year-old just
built the world's tallest
Popsicle-stick structure.
Check this out.
Wow.
-Ooh!
-Oh, yeah, we've got to get
the kids back in school.
It was cute until he said,
"I'm building my own 5G tower
to avoid government
surveillance."
Yep, everyone said,
"Great Eiffel Tower,"
while the kid was like,
"Eiffel Tower?
This is Shaq's toothpick."
We have a great show.